today's episode includes Wolverine free
games and Halloween events so let's get
into it
our first story is a bit of a weird one
because it's talking about Microsoft
possibly revealing the release window
for a game that's not coming to any of
its consoles I'm of course talking about
insomniac's PlayStation exclusive
Wolverine game which the dev first
revealed during a PlayStation showcase
last year and speaking of those
showcases can we get another one this
year I feel like we're a little bit
overdue I'm trying to see some as
spotted by Tech for gamers some recent
filings from Microsoft in relation to
the UK's Activision Blizzard acquisition
investigation claimed that Wolverine
will release in 2023 in the document
Microsoft noted how PlayStation has a
large portfolio of high quality
exclusive content arguing that the
latter wouldn't be massively affected by
the acquisition Microsoft goes on to
note the range of exclusive titles
coming to the console saying quote
PlayStation has a spat of first and
third party exclusive titles lined up
for launch in 2023 including Spider-Man
2 Wolverine Horizon Final Fantasy 16 and
forespoken Insomniac is also developing
Marvel Spider-Man 2 and it assured fans
just this week that the game would still
be out in 2023 however Wolverine doesn't
currently have a release window that
makes the inclusion of this title from
Microsoft and odd one it's unclear if
Microsoft knows something we don't but
it's also just possible that there was a
misinterpretation about Wolverine's
release date on Microsoft's part
somewhere along the line personally I
have my money on 2024. we don't know the
specific date for Spider-Man 2 yet but
I'm assuming whatever that date is
insomniac is going to want a little
breathing room for the game before they
drop another Marvel superhero game not
to mention even though the two aren't
related at all 2024 is going to have the
release of Deadpool 3 and its confirmed
inclusion of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine so
the hype from that movie which is all
already high
could possibly help the Wolverine game
it doesn't need it but it could help it
um you know ride the coattails of that
movie
um and help it in sales so I'm I'm
thinking 2024 for Wolverine but do you
agree with me do you disagree with me
let me know your insomniacs Wolverine
predictions in the comments next up I
want to talk about some free games
because who doesn't love free things for
starters Sims 4 is free to play now on
every platform the game is currently
available for sorry switch players over
on the epic game store you can grab the
Game of the Year Edition of the classic
RPG Fallout 3. and if you're okay with
splitting your purchases between
multiple storefronts and why wouldn't
you be when the game is free then you
can also grab a Microsoft Store version
of Fallout 76 from Amazon Prime gaming
keep in mind that you have to be an
active Prime member to take advantage of
that deal while you're grabbing the 76
code you might as well grab the free
copy of middle Earth's shadow of war
that is redeemable in the Gog store when
it comes to the newest games you can
play on PlayStation Plus make sure to
check out our latest video on the
service in which Lucy James walks you
through what's on offer this month for
subscribers I'll toss the link to that
video in the description one thing that
is great about the Halloween season is
the pumpkin spice takeover the candy and
most importantly the Halloween themed
gaming events that you can participate
in right now fortnite mares has returned
this year with a chunk of fun challenges
for fortnite players to take part in
this year's event sees the return of the
cube monsters first seen last fall
though now with a no build mode twist
the event will be available in game
until November 1st the Apex Legends
fight or fright event has been going on
since October 4th much about this event
is the same as it's always been but this
season there's one major difference for
the first time in Apex Legends history
Shadow Royale will be played on a new
map Olympus after dark fight or fright
will also last until November 1st
Destiny 2's annual wolf Festival of the
Lost event is also underway like
previous years the Halloween themed
celebration will be available for free
to all Destiny 2 players until November
8th now into shooting things Walt Disney
Dream Life Valley has a brand new spooky
star path available now other games that
are taking advantage of the Season
include ooblets Minecraft knockout City
Pikmin Bloom and even multiverses and
more now hit the comment section and let
me know your favorite type of candy but
beware there are wrong answers I'll see
you tomorrow
thank you
[Music]